on October 4th 1992 a 747 200 LL
freighter plane took off from skipple
airport at 5 21 PM UTC
climb for six minutes until according to
the official flight records the plane
encountered a serious problem at 5 27
P.M
on board were three crew members and one
passenger Captain Fuchs first officer
Ohad flight engineer sofa and a
passenger who had hitched a ride to go
to Tel Aviv to marry her future husband
an LL employee who had scored her the
trip
late that afternoon all four felt that
something was seriously wrong the
aircraft
cannon 237 turn that's hitting zero nine
and zero ten minutes
they confirmed and the pilots reported
an engine fire uh
skipple then replied again
I've got Roger heading 270 downwind
around 30 seconds later El all 1862
reported an even larger problems
[Music]
recommended Runway six for a landing
because of a stronger headwind but
Captain Fuchs instead requested Runway
27 which was a longer and closer Runway
but with a Tailwind that would make it
more difficult to land I wondered
the greater difficulty though was that
the aircraft was too high to safely land
at Runway 27 so the aircraft had to Loop
in order to lose enough altitude
and that's when the real problem emerged
our 1062 just to be sure your engine's
number three and four are out
number three and four are out then we
have a problem without net the problem
with the flaps now watch it what the
crew couldn't see in the cockpit was it
the third and fourth engine were not
malfunctioning because of a fire
but because both engines had completely
fallen off of the plane
[Music]
a failure in the fuse pin mechanism in
the third engine have made it so that
the third engine would take the fourth
Engine with it as well as scraping off
the Kruger flaps important Hydraulics
and additional controls were shredded
off as well
and now it had only two options
either thrust and turn uncontrollably
right or stay on the heading without
thrust
the captain was unable to control his
plane
tickets
controls
it would tilt Off The Runway heading and
begin to nose dive
[Music]
the end was inevitable
at 5 35 on October 4th 1992 a cargo
plane carrying four people crashed into
an 11-story Residential Building in
Amsterdam
it's the largest flight disaster to ever
occur on Dutch soil and it's left a lot
of difficult questions unanswered so the
original script for this video was 30
minutes long but the chance for
demonetization was too high so I've
decided to scrap the entire video and
just upload the intro if you want to
support me being able to do bigger
videos that are algorithmically risky
maybe come support me over on nebula I'm
going to start making longer riskier
videos so I can include things I'm not
comfortable saying on YouTube